miss Paula tonight on your last episode  you rode Louie backstage you wrote him a  week we will not forget this Louie is  made this so fun he's made it so much  fun she literally what put a weight on  me you're not going anywhere you were  tired well it's been six weeks it's been  a lot of work how did you feel tonight  when they did say your name that you're  going home you know I can't help but  feel relieved oh because I hadn't been  out there to do my my book signings my  book tour so I'm so ready you know to  get on the road I was actually not  expecting to go home I thought there was  another week and I tell Louie I said I'm  going home tonight I'm going home  tonight I think I'm gonna miss the  physical activity so I'm really hoping  that i will join a dance club along with  my husband Bose